[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors savez vous ce que c'est que vif
serré
avoir un rêve de sorte à ce temps de
crise plus en dormir
on ne pense qu'à ça quand on se lève le
matin mon rêve au rêve
ça peut être très pour vous ça peut être
l'autre pour vous
le moi j'avais un rêve depuis que
j'étais tout petit
c'était d'aller aux jeux olympiques
saurait plus être en tant que volontaire
en tant que technicienne en tant que
compétitrice mais j'y suis allé en tant
qu'arbitre j'ai été la première femme
africaine a officié aux jeux olympiques
c'était à rio en 2016
c'est vrai je les ai dit tantôt j'avais
un rêve mais je suis parti de rien
j'avais rien j'avais juste mon diplôme
d'ingénieur en logistique et transport
allende hp et j'ai eu la chance dans
cette école à laquelle que j'ai
fréquenté plutôt de rencontrer un ange
un ange qui était descendu du ciel
ils étaient venus juste pour moi je
pense
il n'est plus aujourd'hui il est décidé
ça fait un an exactement mais
aujourd'hui je comprends pourquoi il
était véritablement devenue pour moi je
suis persuadé que de là où il est pense
à moi
il veille sur moi ils continuent de le
soutenir et il peut alors se penchent
s'appelle dessous série
mais ce série avait une grande patience
c'était le taekwondo c'était sa richesse
sa plus grande richesse et grâce à lui
j'ai connu le pai points
j'ai passé les craintes tous les jours
je t'ai je suivais ses cours j'étais la
seule fille dans le club de taekwondo
mais je n'avais pas peur
donc j'ai pu passer premier dan 2e dan
3e dan 4e dan 5e dan grâce à lui je suis
celle que vous voyez aujourd'hui et
grâce à lui un matin je me suis dit pour
ne pas devenir arbitres
c'est vrai j'avais fait la compétition
j'ai eu une brève carrière de
compétitrice
j'ai eu une médaille d'or en passant et
j'ai décidé
merci j'ai décidé tout un coup de de
changer parce que voyez vous vous faire
une carrière dans la compétition faut
avoir la taille vous voyez j'ai des
talons c'est pas ma vraie taille
j'avais déjà un handicap c'était une
barrière
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai transformé
cette barrière en l'avantagé la taille
chez shell petite taille je suis à
gilles donc je peux devenir arbitre donc
je reste toujours dans le domaine de la
compétition mais pas en tant que à clé
pas en tant que combattant donc je suis
devenu arbitre
et c'est là que tout a commencé
je me suis dit ok habite nationale c'est
bien mais pourquoi ne pas aller plus
loin
il fallait que je me démarque des autres
arbitres nationaux qui étaient là les
hommes comme des femmes
moi il m'a lu là il fallait que je sois
mieux que je me suis dit pourquoi ne pas
devenir arbitre international j'ai pas
eu peur mais je le disais c'est un
challenge pendant ça va être possible
parce que j'étais une femme
autour de moi il n'y avait que des
hommes j'étais très jeune
tous les arbitres nationaux en côte
d'ivoire il était d'un certain âge donc
évidemment il était prioritaire s'il
fallait aller présenter le texte des
arbitres internationaux
donc j'avais aucune chance
comment ça va être possible pour moi et
puis les circonstances il circonstance
par ont été favorables
et tout s'est mis en place facilement
voyez-vous la fédération ivoirienne de
taekwondo qui normalement présente les
les arbitres nationaux au séminaire des
arbitres internationaux n'a
malheureusement pas eu les moyens cette
année là présenter des arbitres
nationaux
donc il fallait que chacun se prenne en
charge
ok d'accord je retiens ça ensuite je me
renseigne un peu je découvre que le
prochain séminaire des arbitres
internationaux devraient se tenir à
bamako mali
deuxième point tout près de moi ça
aurait pu être n'importe où en chine au
japon au canada
cela me demander beaucoup de moyens
parce qu'il fallait que je parte par mes
propres moyens et j'apprends que c'est à
bamako au mali
ok d'accord je m'appelle emmanuel a donc
joué avec moi on continue ensuite qu'est
ce que j'entends par que j'entends
j'apprends ya une promotion sur les
billets d'avion air mali bon d'accord ok
ça sape répète le hasard donc c'était
décidé il fallait que j'y aille
je prends mon billet et je saute dans la
danse dans l'avion je me rends bamako
s'est pas eu tort parce que je suis
revenu avec le diplôme d'arbitré
international de taille connu mieux
je suis revenu avec le titre de la
première femme ivoirienne habite
internationale en côte d'ivoire
c'était ma première grande victoire
je voulais pas m'arrêter là
je dis ok habite nationale abyss
internationale d'accord c'est bien
mais pourquoi ne pas devenir arbitre
olympique ce best-of niveau voyez vous
croyez moi c'est le top niveau tous les
sportifs même d'une chose d'aller aux
jeux olympiques ok je dit tout à l'heure
que depuis tout petit je rêvais de
partir aux jeux olympiques
et voilà que tout à coup tout s'ouvrait
devant moi il y avait cette possibilité
mais il ne fallait que trente arbitres
dans le monde entier participer aux jeux
olympiques et on était au moins vingt
mille arbres et dans le monde
pour moi est ce que ça l'aide possible
voilà encore d'autres barrières
il fallait prendre au plus trois
arbitres africains qu on était des
milliers en afrique s candidat pour
partir aux jeux olympiques
et un matin on dit en recoupant je sais
plus à moscou au regroupement des
arbitres des meilleurs arbitres
internationaux du monde donc les 1200
meilleur avis est que je reçois le
courrier moi et manuela la fidh
kouassikro je ressens de la côte
d'ivoire imaginez-vous passicos c'est
comme un grain de sable sur la porte à
la carte pardon du monde donc comment
est ce que moi je pouvais être dans
cette liste
ok d'accord
donc je demande un peu des d'un peu
partout parce que la fédération s'est
c'est pas toujours évident dans ceux des
personnes de bonne volonté mois et des
seuils là je vais prendre mon billet je
suis parti à man
et tenez vous bien de 1200 candidats de
1200 candidats pardon on ne devrait
prendre que 50
et à près de 50 passer à 30 des 1200
on dit aux africains
au mieux non
un marocain deuxièmement un sud africain
après on dit une ivoirienne
pas deux ivoirienne perceuse donc j'ai
sauté au plafond c'est qu'autant de
galles versus ailleurs j'appelle les
paroles c'est important il m'a dit
écoute ma fille
on te soutient on est avec toi on sait
que sa valise et je n'ai pas hésité je
suis allé voir ma mère ma patronne elle
est là dans la salle je lui ai dit
écoutez l'aisne dont il aurait put est
averti et
j'avais un rêve c'était d'aller aux jeux
olympiques
et donc il faudrait pas que le travail
soit un frein pour moi donc il faut
plutôt encourager l a dit là pas de
problème je te soutiens on est ensemble
je vais te couvrir c'est ainsi que oui
il faut la poser elle est là c'est ainsi
que quelquefois le vendredi à midi ou à
17 heures je prends ma valise je me
rends l'aéroport après avoir travaillé
dur comme tout le monde je me rends à la
compétition pour arriver le lendemain
matin autour de 6 heures du matin je
dors à peine dans l'avion j'arrive sur
la compétition tout fatigué dès que je
finis le dimanche ou le lundi je prends
l'avion
j'arrive à abidjan autour de 4 heures du
matin et je me change en l'aéroport et
je viens au bureau je travaille ça m'a
demandé beaucoup d'organisations parce
que pour arriver
à cette fin il faut du courage il faut
beaucoup de détermination
il faut de la persévérance et
franchement quand je regarde pour ce que
j'ai eu à faire
je me dis que c'est important et le
tintement de marée permis d'apprendre
plusieurs choses
le contrôle de soi le courage
la courtoisie les dégripper et toutes
les valeurs que j'avais en moi vous
pousser à être celle que vous voyez
actuellement
mais ce n'est pas fini j'ai été retenu
dans le lot des 50 meilleurs arbitres il
fallait prendre maintenant 30
et comme la patronne avait donné le ok
vous faire tous ces voyages
j'ai voyagé comme ça tout le temps
pendant deux ans c'était fatigant
travail paye moins de travail taekwondo
pas de vie personnelle pas de vie privée
j'avais rien pour les économies étaient
partis mais j'avais toujours la foi
il fallait que j'y aille avec je réalise
mes rêves fallait que je prie se marier
parce que il y avait jamais d'habitants
enfin olympique afrique et il fallait
que je sois la première et j'ai foncé
j'ai pas hésité et donc après avoir fait
tout ce périple comme je suis là dit
tout à l'heure un soir dans la nuit dans
le dit mardi aux environs de 4 heures du
matin je reçois un email dans lequel on
annonce que je suis sélectionné ou aller
aux jeux olympiques de rio
j'appelais j'ai appelé tout le monde
j'ai appelé mon père qui dormait cydia
j'appelle la mère patrie boss j'appelle
racer pas de réponse j'appelle qui bat
série il était le seul à décrocher il a
décroché il était très content il a dit
vraiment et manu là je te remercie parce
que grâce à toi j'ai pu vivre ce rêve là
avec toi
alors ce que je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que pour atteindre ses
rêves
il faut vivre ses rêves d'abord mais
pour atteindre serait faire beaucoup de
sacrifices
moi j'ai beaucoup trimé g&g sa fille si
beaucoup de choses comme je le dis ton
tour j'avais pas de vie personnelle je
pouvais avoir les dernières perruque à
la mode les derniers sacs à main griffés
mais toutes les économies tout ce que
j'avais c'était pour mon sport
c'était pour pouvoir arriver à mes fins
pouvoir aller à rio
et j'y suis arrivé pourquoi pas vous
alors pour résumer tout ce que j'ai eu à
vous dire
pour pouvoir vivre ses rêves il faut
d'abord avoir rêve c'est la première des
choses il faut avoir un rêve il est
important d'avoir un rêve une vie sans
rien c'est une vie vite
voilà j'avais un rêve c'était de partir
à rio
ensuite faut avoir quoi de la volonté je
me suis dit je veux
moi je voulais aller à rio c'est vrai
aujourd'hui j'ai autre chose en tête
mais à l'époque je voulais aller à rio
je me suis dit je veux je me suis donné
les moyens qu'il fallait en restant
fidèle à mes valeurs et à mon sens
prononcé de l'éthique c'est très
important
j'avais cette volonté se taire le début
des charges commencé à discuter à
échanger au comprendre ce que c'était
que le taekwondo
ensuite il faut du courage beaucoup de
courage
comme je le dis j'ai voyagé j'ai trimé
j'ai souffert mais je n'ai pas abandonné
donc j'ai fait tout ça voilà ça fait un
peu garçon mais bon je suis une femme
mais bon c'est pas compliqué ensuite de
la persévérance il faut persévérer
rien n'est facile dans la vie y aura
toujours des échecs ceux qui m'ont
précédé logique alors le plus dur n'est
pas d'échouer et de se relever lorsqu'on
tombe donc il faut chaque fois aller
plus loin et ensuite je veux dire le la
finalité de tout ça c'est
l'accomplissement l'accomplissement
c'est tous nous avait mis en oeuvre pour
pouvoir appelle le but que vous vous
êtes fixé moi mon applaudissements
c'était ça
valerio voilà donc vous voyez vous voyez
je suis là au milieu avec sur le tapis
de rio est donc jamais le rêve
vous avez la volonté le courage et la
persévérance donc chercheurs je vous
invite
franchement je dirais pas suivre mon
exemple
mais si ça peut vous inspirez que cela
vous permettent de vivre pleinement vos
rêves en restant fidèle aux valeurs
c'est très important et à l'éthique
[Applaudissements]